[Musique]
oui bernat parole autochtone 6000 sa
mort lundi puis cette main de jeu et
revenir un peu sur ma chronique de la
semaine dernière où je parlais la
nomination de mérici mincom 30e
gouverneur général un rôle qui pour la
première fois se rendaient entre les
mains d'une famine aucune femme qui
quand même
quelqu'un même un parcours professionnel
extrêmement intéressant donc c'est un
rôle qui lui ai je pas volé mais la
discussion tourne beaucoup autour du
fait d'avoir une famille inouk à ce rôle
qui est vue pour par beaucoup parlent
comme un rôle coloniale donc la
discussion était très très riche très
intéressant parce qu'on parle aussi de
la perception de la communauté inox
verse la communautés des premières
nations puisque nos parcours historique
sont pas les mêmes et ça l'a vraiment
fait ressortir pour moi dans les
commentaires des fois l'ignorance que
les gens ont du paysage politique
autochtone versus le paysage politique
québécois et canadien
il existe une très grande distinction
très grande différence mais dans des
subtilités on s'attend au québec au
canada critiquer commenté ne pas être
d'accord avec un pote un parti politique
ou un politicien au sein d'un parti
politique c'est tout c'est un droit
c'est un droit social primordial les
gens ont le droit de faire de l'ironie
endroit de rêve après tout sauf insulter
ou carrément menacé un politicien mais
la satire politique fait partie d'une
manière que la population a toujours eu
aussi accès pour pouvoir se délester
parfois une frustration envers une
classe dirigeante qu'elle est il donc là
c'est de dire que l est au pouvoir parce
qu'elle a été choisie on a la chance
d'avoir ça au canada
la différence que des fois je vois qui
n'est pas comprise pour ce qui vient des
communautés autochtones ci qui a une
dynamique politique quand même très
différentes nos politiciens se rajoutant
à ceux des politiciens canadiens
québécois car comme c'est un état
colonial et a forcé
un format politique sur les communautés
même si certaines communautés ne
connaissent pas les partis politiques
les milieux politiques comme étant des
représentants des communautés
autochtones il reste que présentement
elles ont un pouvoir au dessus des
communautés donc elle met en jeu des
enjeux autochtones sans nécessairement
avoir la reconnaissance des communautés
autochtones c'est ce qui a fait que par
le passé par exemple les communautés
sont parmi celles qui vote le moins aux
élections municipales provinciales
fédéral mais pourtant dans nos
communautés on vote on est actif parce
que dans les communautés salle a un
impact direct sur vous et de comprendre
que ces politiques là qu'elles viennent
par exemple du conseil de vente qui est
sous la loi sur les indiens qui viennent
du conseil traditionnel qui viennent
même des organismes qui sont politiques
je pense par exemple femmes autochtones
du québec ou à la paix actuels qui ont
une voix forte politique mais qui ne
sont pas des partis politiques qui ne
sont pas des représentants politiques de
toutes les communautés autochtones ça
l'a quand même les parents c'est une
voie politique importante dans le
paysage québécois et canadien et bien
c'est une amicale sont très différentes
il faut pas oublier
que les communautés ont
des ressources a distribué dans les
communautés qui sont issus de tout ce
qui est du droit municipal provincial et
fédéral donc imaginé un parti qui
auraient tous ses pouvoirs et qui aurait
plus de distinction entre le
professionnel le fédéral ça serait
vraiment quelqu'un qui aurait beaucoup
beaucoup de pouvoir donc pendant très
longtemps le parti le milieu on voit le
particulier le milieu politique
autochtone on était un très discret les
critiques sont très peu ouvert où sont
faits plus dans les conversations
privées parce qu'elles peuvent avoir
selon les communautés pour vraiment pas
généraliser mais selon les communautés
peuvent avoir on n'est pas énorme sur
pro quotidien sur comme une maison
venait d'allouer si tu vas recevoir du
financement pour les études salahin est
pas
ce qui est différent dernièrement c'est
qu'en ayant des politiciens du milieu
autochtone qui s'en vont vers des
politiques provinciales fédéral qui vont
voir des rôles par exemple à la
nomination d'une sénatrice et nous un
premier rôle eh bien on voit un
dégagement du milieu politique un
désencombrement et une ouverture
justement d'une capacité à venir
discuter sur des plateformes beaucoup
plus large mais ce que ça fait c'est que
ça aussi démocratiser la voix des gens
des communautés et de plus en plus on
entend des critiques on entend des
commentaires on entend aussi des êtres
des insatisfactions auto des politiciens
autochtone que par le passé on
n'entendait pas nécessairement un
exemple par exemple quand on a eu un
réveil sur la distinction justement des
idéologies politiques je pense j'utilise
souvent l'exemple en 2012 est drôlement
quand thérèse aspen les chefs ont voulu
rencontrer
sinon avec vannes en général justement
il y avait eu une énorme mobilisation
autochtone et les chefs avaient
finalement été à la rencontre de stephen
harper mais c'était pas nécessairement
dans l'alignement du grand groupe qui
avait milité donc quand cette rencontre
a eu lieu ensuite à continuer les
mobilisations d'iron man et les gens
comprenaient pas pourquoi elle continuer
puisque les chefs avaient eu ce qu'ils
voulaient la rencontre avec stephen
harper teresa spence avait rencontré et
ça l'est vraiment faire ressortir le
fait qu'il y avait une classe politique
distincte du aussi d'une mobilisation
sociale et que nos idéaux était pas en
ligne et sur des mêmes choses que nos
désirs politiques n'étaient pas les
mêmes et on ne travaillait pas non plus
sur les mêmes plateformes donc certains
travailler sur des milieux politiques
dont était plus grasse route et venait
venait porter des messages qui venait
des communautés qui étaient souvent
bloqués justement par le manque de
présence dans les plateformes médias
dans les plateformes politiques et c'est
pas pour négliger le fait qu'on a eu
beaucoup de chefs qui sont venus marcher
avec nous
dans l'autre sens où si on a des
personnes qui sont venues de la
militance 3 août qui sont allés dans des
rôles de chair ou de conseiller dans
leurs communautés donc faut pas voir ça
comme séparer et fermer c'est qu'il ya
une fluidité pareil comme pour au canada
et au québec entre nous mobilisation qui
fait qu' on a des idées option tyran ou
note des positions qui sont différents
pourquoi je dis c'est aujourd'hui
pourquoi est-ce que je commente là
dessus c'est que aussitôt qui a une
nomination dans un milieu politique
québécois canadiens une personne
autochtone bien son identité prend une
place très importante dans le message
politique québécois et canadiens parce
qu'on défonce un plafond de verre on
défonce une limite qui nous a été
imposée et ses rôles sont enfin en fait
des communautés autochtones ou à des
personnes des communautés autochtones
alors ça des faits quelque chose qui de
ce système là extrêmement exclusifs ou
raciste ils savent bien transformer ce
milieu là cependant constant après
savoir le milieu autochtone d'où
viennent les personnes eh bien il faut
s'attendre à ce qu'il y ait des
commentaires des critiques il faut
s'attendre à ce que les parcours de ces
personnes n'en ont pas été exemple ou
sans tache
et quand après ça le discours des
communautés commence à être libéré à
venir parler justement de ce héros
l'avenir moi je peux content que on est
une gouvernante générale autochtone je
pense est enrôlé pour décoloniser je
suis pas contente que ça se fait ça
parce que c'est des rôles que nous on ne
reconnaît pas il est des fois on n'a pas
le message qui vient de l'otan s'est dit
vous devriez être content enfin une
personne autochtone moi je vais être
content pour 7 personnes autochtones et
jeudi si on devait être content pour
toutes les personnes qui sont élus
est-ce que tu serais content pour une
personne à l'automne et de l'ue juste
parce qu'elles étaient à le plaindre non
tu demanderais le même niveau de
devoir qu'à n'importe quel autre
policier nous autres c'est la même chose
on eu des critiques des commentaires
mais souvent parce que la personne ait
choisi est autochtone on nous demande un
certain silence pour pouvoir permettre à
la gloire à l'étoile de briller alors
que nécessairement ça veut pas dire
qu'il n'ya pas quelque chose qui s'est
passé dans le passé d'ailleurs justement
monde si tu te demandes si quelque chose
qui est déséquilibré dans les milieux
politiques écoutent le silence il est
criant donc est ce que vous entendez
beaucoup de commentaires vous entendez
beaucoup de critiques est présentement
c'est très difficile de les avoir
puisque et ça c'est très très très très
très important de comprendre pourquoi
cette dynamique le existe encore quand
une personne attaque tonnes vient dans
un roe de pouvoir politique autochtone
il est à la merci de commentaires
dégradants
d'une double comme je suis une double
attente par rapport à la tenir son rôle
et si quelque chose fait
trébucher ces politiques cette politique
la critique vaut pas uniquement vers la
personne l'individuel vox vers la
communauté d'origine et ça c'est
malheureusement quelque chose qui doit
se transformer dans la politique
canadienne et québécoise
sans pour autant bloquer la parole des
citoyens autochtones et de leur réalité
dans leurs communautés parce que pour
l'instant elles ne sont pas encore
combinées elles sont encore très disney
donc nous a mis une grosse creux n'est
que cette semaine je vous ai amené aussi
une vision qui est très difficile une
vision qui est pas nécessairement porté
par tout le monde il ya beaucoup de gens
qui veulent pas qu'on puisse nous offrir
même une chance de pour être critiqués
parce que on est tellement fragilisé par
justement la pression qui viennent
l'état colonial par la pression des
d'écoles du racisme habituel donc en
laissant traîner quelqu'un c'est certain
qu'on offre à la communauté la capacité
de voir des modèles de réussite mais par
exemple on veut pas non plus par se
retrouver avec des histoires comme par
le passé à
une répercussion sur la communauté et on
a eu des sénateurs qui ont été plus ou
moins bon et on veut pas se retrouver
non plus avec des personnes qui vont mal
représenté un rôle pour ensuite voir une
petite x interrogé vers la communauté au
grand complet donc vous comprenez qu'on
se trouve dans un tournant historique
mais ça veut pas dire de faire taire la
voix des citoyens sinon on n'est plus
dans une démocratie et de voir que ces
voix là sont pas toujours contente sont
pas toujours
en accord avec le modèle politique
actuelle ce sont des voix de
transformation si on avait gardé le
silence et on ne veut garder silence et
des black light marines prépas et les
transformations sociales importantes qui
ont lieu maintenant n'aurait pas lieu
donc juste de garder l'oeil ouvert pour
les commentaires inutiles pour le
racisme habituel et
ouvrir nos canaux voir nos esprits à la
nouveauté que le mélange de ces milieux
politiques la vanille alors merci
beaucoup pour votre écoute c'était une
longue chronique mais je pense qu'elle
est nécessaire parce que c'est une
discussion d'avenir et cd rom on va
avoir de plus en plus occupés par des
communautés ou par des membres des
communautés autochtones et c'est les
rôles qu'ils vont être des fois
où se déroule qui vont peut-être servir
de cheval de troie d'un côté ou de
l'autre alors soit on rentre dans le
milieu politique allochtone et on
commence à l'éviter ou soit le politique
les nominations politiques autochtones
elles vont commencer à rentrer dans les
communautés pour habiter l'esprit des
communautés et c'est là où est ce qu'il
ya des dangers pour nous en tant que
petite communauté qui sont quand même
encore fragile sur le milieu est alors
merci beaucoup à caen jeudi pour cette
écoute parce que c'est vraiment un sujet
difficile soit une belle semaine